[Musique]
pour recevoir les amis j'ai bien cru
qu'avec tout ce chargement nous
n'arriverions jamais bombe soit aux os x
nounours j'ai bien l'impression que tu
devrais vite aller coucher ses jeunes
joueurs sans roues oui patron bon le
seul ballon passait devant moi bel veut
la faire attention de ne pas tomber
totaux à bientôt patron mais tu oublies
ton arbre de noël nounours tiens ce que
je suis chargé qu'on me au second et
soyez bien sages les oursons qui les
chargeait non
bonsoir les enfants n'osent pas en paix
ils sont timides les chérubins entrées
dont mes petits en leur sein jantes et
voici rémy et le petites autos sont
frais et sans fond il est très timide
[Musique]
souvent faim oh la la quiche il en
annonce mais pas beaucoup démené ce sont
des bébés ils ne savent pas encore parti
qu'est ce que tu as apporté une nurse
voilà un beau sapin de nos montagnes que
vous envoient leur moment pour noël
chère amy ya quelques heures d'or et 7
la peau livre d'image emilia m'a aussi
chargé de vous dire que ces oursons sont
très gentils
rémy ne va pas la cuisine tout seul
ils sont très jeunes ils ont apporté
leur biberon au miel avec eux pour
s'endormir le soir
le matin il leur faut une bonne petite
soupe houlette avec du miel à midi
enfants ne touche pas la langue
tu vas te brûler
[Musique]
il mangera table avec nous oui et tout
où est passé tout haut on se leurre de
l'efb et rouge musical aaron les couches
regarde nous nous voulons préparer un
beau père tout ce qu'ils les jeunes à
long ou d'auto mes petits poussins chéri
[Musique]
sont pas très obéissante n 20 bien sûr
les chérubins émises lama bien
recommander que vous leur chantier une
petite berceuse pour les endort c'est
inquiète pas surtout à la tuque et vient
des mains bien sûr
bonsoir les enfants de ben moi c'est la
fin de la journée
le moment de ce projet nous paye donc
comme nos amis ils seront tous au lit
non c'est long aussi sur son nuage shirt
à maman le marchand de sable à temps il
nous dira termine mieux et dom et
oublient de nous sommes bien dans notre
lit en anjou à aubenas nuit chaque
branche voire important
réfléchir je vais m'endormir je vais
m'endormir fait comme les gentils neveu
nounours y comme nicolas et pimprenelle
aller vite au dodo d'ailleurs je suis
sûr qu'ils dorment déjà à saint-saud sur
patron ils sont soumis nos bonnes idées
enfants fait de borel faute de bourem
bonne nuit
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]